車
はっはっは
me
ee
換気郡俺は何度言っていて今年はお菓子ジュースが食べれない中でお祭りに行っても
現在見てもかき氷が食べないんです
ツンなマジでまず列んだろ偉人祭にしたんですけどほとんど屋台が終わってて怒って
自衛隊が3つウィング飴チョコバーナー書ボイ
僕はその祭で何を食べることもなくそのまま家に帰ったとさ
さようならて家は凄い飯食いゴリてを買ったらネオン街がシロップへんもんねジュース
なんですよ僕の中でシロップ意外なところでいかにかき氷ように美味しく食べれるかを
強調と言うんで買ってきたんで話はシロップ以外でどうすれば
鍵おり美味しく食べれるか今日は検証していきたいとおもいますてないバーン
ポケモンゴーやりて本当に俺は純正ニューかき氷をちょっと食べたいと思っているから
ですといろいろ試してみましょうそれで光量物米を食べにくるはず
ん
なんで冷蔵庫壊れて濃厚にしか入ってなかったんでよかったんですけどもう全部
ドロドロでした
夏っぽくなってきたねおっしゃった鍵をで作っていきますひとまず
うんはい協議で僕はここでシロップをかけると食べれないので何をかけるかという話
まずはこちらまずは音今朝爪におっさをかけると思います
おちゃん風味を感じをみたいな作戦ちょっと行ってみようと思う
じゃゲイストーリーますかねえ
完全ににをいただきます顎がしている各号るー
みたいですね
ううっうぅうううぅ
と嬉しい
次はこちら方面のめんつゆでこれはね俺で漫才いけると思ってるんだよねこれも8頭
変換って言いますかもうかき氷をかき氷甘いものそして水面性によっても料理として
食べ物としてみるという作戦です
ok バーンマニュアルやで歩い風味がかなりようにこれは悪くないですよ
免税ぽっこりだけもう
んです次はこちら右腕それにを意識って話を聞きました
販売
あっ
まあ23歳になってからフィールが美味しく感じるんだよ
疲れてます
使用した
ワンッ浴びてあげすっ
ビールだけの方が
美味しいああ
次はこちらケチャップでシャツともまたどう出るかわかんないところねー
押せケチャッとか
貴族かけでしょ
ああなんかありそうこんな感じですこれは何かね割とねいける気がします
うんいただけます
うーん何ですかね何か違うやっぱりケチャップはね氷だとね
まだケチャップのが強すぎて降魔がかき氷本来の力がサーブで封じられたか鬱やこちら
牛乳でピュッにニャー練乳だねっっ
ハチミツですこれはねお菓子の蜂蜜じゃないよ本当に純粋な髪蜜っていうのは
めちゃくちゃ栄養価が高い砂糖だの大跳びなしの関連100%蜂蜜なんでもう目指した
健康に良いです
サブみんなが思っているようなちょっと美味しいハチミツと味が違うのでそこが
果たして安芸郡にどう出るかがポイントでございますなんかそれらしくなりました
いや普通にうまそ
あー小岩ああ
次はこちら多摩のタマゾンでございます貼ってをもう片方いるかもしれませんがよく
考えてみてください
はやばい卵かけご飯パシフィックてないご飯に卵と醤油をかけるだけであれほど場での
風味が生まれかき氷もしっかり中が凍って見えましての卵とそういうをかけるだけで
あっという間にご飯に圧倒あっ
という間に行くと at られかき氷じゃなくなってね前にでしょこま茨城県するじゃ
ない子なんだこれが美味しいかどうかです
par 4
ます
ん
愛と会で色々試してみましたものの蜂蜜とビールが切りかなあとは本当に何勝手なを
いなしているものでかき氷にはやっぱりシロップで一番だと思いました
ポケモンゴー外でやるとき火をつけられなぁ
さてちょっと行こう